[Music]
hey welcome to every damn day so we're
talking about this Kylie Jenner who's a
billionaire to be appeared on the cover
of GQ with her boyfriend Travis Scott
he's wearing a suit let's take a look at
it she's not wearing much this is
exciting because it's the first time
that they've had an official photo shoot
together since the birth of their
daughter stormy five months ago people
are talking about it you can see that
scar on her leg guys what do we think is
this how you look when you pose with
your significant other I thought where
Kylie's boob is I thought that was the
head of a baby it was parents now but
like yeah we're still I thought that I
thought it was like a Bjorn holding the
baby that sounds like a party game or
instead of passing an orange like that
you just have to hold a baby by pressing
your body I'll try it at my next night
pool party so as a part to promote this
photo shoot there's also this GQ video
that she was quizzing Travis Kylie was
get-to-know-you questions I guess they
don't live together yeah what do you
guys think when should a couple move in
together and this in this day and age I
honestly I feel like if you're rich
never yeah they live together yeah live
in the same state maybe the same town
like it's like it's like his and her
sinks but for your life
yeah does your husband know that this is
your opinion we talk about it all really
we're rich enough like yeah you'll have
a row
I'll just because I apparently will cut
this up really when I read my Kindle in
bed this is to distress yeah I like I
can't have a book because apparently the
way I turn the pages - laughs Kindle
like it I like this his and her sinks
for like the entire I think they should
go one step further and just make
another baby and then each raise
themselves great so everybody has equal
like child and home and everything just
his in her lives yeah just separate it
everyone living separately is so foreign
to me because whenever I'm gonna date
with someone like I immediately thinking
like wait how how fast can I move in
with you say friend I'm saying like yeah
not for love but like could you be but
if money is not an issue then yeah I
live alone yeah crazy now I was
definitely I'm I'm married now folks but
when I don't relax all the comments that
have been you know proposing to me and
coming on to me let it go but when I was
dating in my 20s I would be like on a
first date like okay I think I love you
should we which I recently upgraded from
a twin bed I okay so I wow I thought
people were just teasing me that a twin
bed was bad but I found out from
ex-girlfriends that I was like very
uncomfortable to sleep in that's before
she moved away she said just one
yeah this was a few months ago I got a
fool cuz my coworker gave it away you
got to just get it bad it's so expensive
it's worth it you're gonna sleep in it
every night you use shoes every day yeah
Jordan you like we're supremo okay so I
think our advice is you can afford it
get your own bed but if you have to
really afford it get your own houses
I think we've tracked that one I think
we've got some YouTube shoutouts to do
actually yeah you got one from yes we
have a really comment so the question
that we posed was how did you fail on
your driver's license and I just really
like this comment from Joseph Gallardo
he says licenses to both dance and drive
revoked thanks for the comment we're
gonna do something different right now
[Music]
welcome to relationship roundup I'm Ryan
I'm going to be answering real
relationship questions to help you guys
and you can trust me I have a girlfriend
already let's start a neighbor garden
I'm gonna be giving that woman's
perspective I'm like classical girls
girl I love talking about boys having
cocktails and drinking glue all right
just to clarify she's not my girlfriend
she's just some kind of swamp woman and
she sits here at clarification point I
am a swamp lady but I do come from a
long line this one win it let's chat
really suggest good idea first question
comes from Elise in Dayton Ohio Elise
asked the guy I've been dating for two
months is not as religious as I am can
we make it work good question Elise this
is a tough one I would suggest that the
best path here is to communicate with
your boyfriend how your faith is
important to you and that you'd like to
share it with them
listen girlfriend the only person he
needs to worship is you yes click that
and the little aliens that we all know
live in the apartments in the craters of
the moon
I mean what's a girl got to do to get
one of those crater apartments all right
our next question comes from our YouTube
community page Michael Windsor glend
asks how do I win my ex back after a
terrible breakup
ooh boy Michael don't do it it's a
controversial one for me but I say don't
do it you broke up for a reason and
unless you were married or you have kids
or something cut them loose get out of
there I agree with Ryan get him loose I
wish I could do the same with the
Beatles in my shoes they just keep
coming back yeah every morning I'm like
Harry they're more butyl in the shoes
maybe I should stop putting the bread
crumbs in they shave no they need the
bread crumbs for the South Souls all
right next question
next question comes from Ashley in
California Ashley says her boyfriend
doesn't make her feel special anymore
what do I do
Ashley oh my gosh what do we got here a
big question a big part of a
relationship is recognizing that you
have value that you should be
appreciated so if he doesn't appreciate
you this is an issue if it's all about
connecting with yourself and finding out
what you like I know all I want is a big
bowl of cereal filled to the brim with
glue
hashtag girls night you're right I
didn't bring enough to share that's
right it's rude you're right okay all
right our next question comes from will
and Champaign Illinois will simply ask
I'm shy how do I ask girls our Willie
come on baby this is this is easy
there's lots of Revenue's now for shy
people online dating that's a big one
just start with a normal pleasant
conversation why don't we get a drink
sometime yes booth never hurt anybody
it's the lubricant of the masses you
know my favorite cocktail is one part
vermouth one parts lime three parts
lunch
hashtag is five o'clock somewhere oh no
this is very good that looks like toilet
water uh yeah you wish oh no don't don't
oh I feel sick inside remembers you had
a drink by what it smells like and
tastes like that's exactly what you
should judge a drink by no that's what
my uncle the locksmith says he used to
be a chef at home I'm gonna be sick
thanks for watching I'm Chris Kyle and
I'm here rapper deaf free right right
and you might remember him from a clip
we show it on every damn day he goes
every turn right so we're about to play
a little game we wanna have you guess
whether somebody Celebes wear boxers
briefs but nothing to me okay
got him Justin Bieber what do you think
he's doing I think he I think he goes I
think it goes briefs on him but I think
he also like most like when he has to
but like I think he'll take every
opportunity to just commando it out so
you think it depends on the situation so
let's say if I hey beer if you come to
my cookout if he's at the cookout what
did he wear nothing
Brad Pitt I think he's g-string out oh
so you think he going with your nose go
brief which is the g string g string out
dude just right up the butt crack right
there
Dwayne Dwayne the rock Johnson his last
name is Johnson yeah yeah it's tribal
tribal proprieties wears a loincloth man
in general I would rock the club look I
don't have a loincloth but not in the
same room with the rock yeah he's a
homebody when I use boxers all day him
as Chris Pratt boxers him as star-lord
from guards the galaxy's losing he's
wearing nothing star-lord
I agree I had a facility with it Will
Smith what do you think he's rocking
options definitely jiggy with that I
think he'll like when he's hanging out
Brad Pitt he'll rock a g-string together
and like other times there's been a
family man just boxers you know what I'm
saying I think around the house he
probably he probably wears a robe with
nothing underneath it
you think he's a naked guy he's a road
guy the road guy with his slippers yeah
Donald Trump what do we think he's
wearing Donald Trump you gotta cover it
wears long jaws cool long guy wears long
a red pair with the thing in the bank
that left the butt cheeks oh absolutely
any probably changes call it Tony we
need along one more a little guy named
definitely a stud he's right here
so death it's obvious baby boxers all
day long that was just boxers briefs or
nothing underneath and we're here was
the resident expert debt free thanks
again if they coffee my friend do you
guys remember MTV Cribs yeah so my dream
bed is the bed that Shaquille O'Neal
it's like I think like three king-sized
beds and because he's such a giant
person and then it's like and his wife
and all of their dogs are in the bed
this red plush bed and it goes in a
circle so he would like turn a thing and
it would go 360 it's like man why the
360 is that a sex thing I must be know I
think it helps you put the sheets on
[Laughter]
there you go that's that doesn't prove
my point at all
yeah I should get one of those you know
fun fact
check for watches he needs to watch
bands that are linked together too you
know that was a fun fact that was and
you know where I see you next time in
everybody where do you find it
I was in a spa and his jeweler told me
that oh well then that sounds like a lot
that's a less fun fact
ya know fun fact he was in a hot tub
with this good yeah okay back to being
fun you see you next time on everything
[Music]
you